You
It is I the madam has arrived
Wait, some of the girls are like selling the general chat from our meeting
Okay, everybody's good
Yeah, the meeting is fine. No, it's really just like what we do we just really have a catch up be like oh, this is what we did good
This is probably what we got to work on
Do you need help with this? So it was yeah, it was good fresh room. No, actually, I stay pretty quiet
I talked a lot a lot the last meeting so I wanted to I
Didn't want to like overtake other people or something in case something came up
Oh my god, that's loud
Turn it down
So I thought we play a little bit of Elden ring. Hold on. I want to go creep on them
I'm gonna creep on the girls
Boo I'm streaming
Everybody say hi
Wow
Are you guys doing anything inappropriate in here? Yes. Yes
We're all jerking it together. Oh
I'll leave you then enjoy your
Yeah, usually people will hang out after the meeting I I wish I could but I already said I was gonna do a gorilla
I hope I didn't scare them too bad
Hey you three I was Azura um in me and Mercy
No, it's not that what do you guys don't say that that's not what that's about at all
They invite me to the Jork I'm missing out on the Jork. That's fine. I can talk to them
Um, but we're gonna play a little bit the three biggest goobers accurate
accurate
I think I see one back to sleep or she's gonna. I don't know. I don't think she went back to sleep. She has a stream today
No, Jorking so I have the new controller so hopefully
Um
Everything works properly Rena has been in my lap this entire time during the meeting and she's fallen asleep and I can't she's very big
And I can't hold her up on my legs any longer ma'am. Can you wake up?
Excuse me ma'am
Hello ma'am
I know I don't want to drop I don't want to drop it
I just
I don't want to accidentally drop Rena because she's like she's not like on my lap
She's so like I have my legs on top of my foot rest and I I'm like
And she my blankets over them. So she's like sitting in the blanket in between my legs like a little hammock
And it's funny because she looks like she's popping out of a little like a
Little rabbit hole because she's just sinking into the blanket where her head is above
And it's funny
She's company the company learning company secret not even it's literally just a rehash of what we did this month
Yeah, you guys
I'm quite tired. I
Was really anxious during the meeting, but I didn't like do anything
I was always anxious because I'm like, oh, can I do better? I hope I hope I pleased everybody
I hope everything's good, but it was a good meeting. Yeah
It was good. It was um, it was better than the last summer
Not that we were productive
Hi, she be it's me fun time 40 and welcome to Elden Ring lightning strike
By a whale guitar if please
But I forget where we were to be honest with you
I know you beat the dancing lion and I don't know where we were going after that
I'm still riding my high on beating the dancing lion. I was talking to my dad yesterday about him playing
Him playing um watch him a call it
Elden ring instead of black myth mukong
Did I go? Oh, yeah, I'm outside of a Lana
That's three right. You're right because I was fighting that one dude that was there and I was just like running around a bunch
Um, right now. I can't get over how funny you look right now. Oh my god. You look like a little
How are you is this comfortable for you
You're slowly falling deeper into the blanket
And making my legs hurt because I'm out of all an angle to keep you up and not fall on the ground
Okay, I'm gonna pick you up. Oh
My god, she almost fell out of the blanket
Oh, I need to stretch my legs. Oh my god, she kept chewing on my headphones during the meeting
Sinking into the comfy
Okay, no, but now Rena's on my shoulder and I can't do anything. I can't play one-handed
Reena I'm sorry
She's probably gonna squeak an annoyance when I try to put her on the floor. She used me ma'am. Can you one on hook?
She's squeaked an annoyance. You couldn't hear it, but she was like
Thank you. Bye-bye
She found a height. No, she's been running a boomie has been like terrorizing her this morning
So she kept running over to me. Um, oh
Oh, the mama doll the papa's all tweets are actually cute. Yeah, they were
My mom was so shy like you should have seen how red my mom's face got I'm like mom
Why are you blushing so hard? You're just saying hi
She's like I like I get put in the spot. Yeah, me and my mom have very similar voices
Sometimes when I talk to my dad on the phone, he's just like
Dal is that you?
And I was like no, it's me she be and he's just like, oh, can you put your mother on the phone, please?
But yeah, you can kind of see like with my parents voices like my voice range
Like my mom is like
She's like a little bit higher pitch than me
But she sounded really goofy and the the mess the voice tweets because she was really like shy
But normally she's like talks like a little bit higher
And not as goofy because she was like and doing oh
She's doing that kind of
But yeah, you met chef
My dad I was like, okay guys
I came up with the names for you for the stream and my dad's like oh I get to name myself
And I'm like no dad. He's like I want to be Peter and I'm like what he's like Peter rabbit. I'm like dad stop
I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're very clever. You're very clever dad
You're not you're not gonna be pita pita rabbit
And my dad's just like so where's my bourbon and I'm like I haven't I don't know
Maybe I'll put that as like a donut thon birthday donut thon thing like I get my dad the bourbon bottle
But he my dad oh my god
I didn't tell you guys this yesterday, but my dad like almost made me cry in a good way because um I
Was talking about how I broke my controller and you guys got me a new one and he's like, you know what?
I'm gonna give you my scuff controller, and I'm like what he's like. Yeah, like I never used it
It's too big for my it's too small for my hands
He's like like the paddles keep like I keep accidentally touching the paddles
So he gave me his $300 scuff controller and I'm like
Bro, and he's like, you know, I know you'll put it to better use than I ever will it's just gathering dust
And I'm just like
So I'll probably use that for some of the FPS games
For next week
But I really like the controller you guys got me. It's actually
Slightly different than I thought it was
That controller I got used from GameStop, and I'm wondering if it was a knockoff because this looks so much different from it
Like it's the same color, but it's red and not like the other one was kind of purple II I realized
But yeah, I was watching my dad like top frag
He got 37 kills and cod and everybody else was like 18 17
I was I was pretty proud. I was like, oh wow you've actually improved my mom's like
Yeah, he all he does is just play this all day
And I'm like, wow, he's like if you ever want to play if you ever want to play a hop in a lobby with you
I'll hop in a lobby and I'm like, okay, dad
Game mode. I don't know. I can't remember. I wasn't paying attention. I was mostly talking to my mom
Excuse me and you're laughing at pictures of my grandfather because it looks like he was wearing a really bad toupee and
Why is the music get louder? Hello
Music's too loud. Do I look better by the way? I'm at a higher bit rate
However, I I do drop frames I
Don't know why I don't know if it like if I lag or anything. Do I look better bring that salvation true
See me to call it a she-fi stuff. I do look better. I seem crisper. Oh, thank goodness. Yeah manager
It was telling me my how my fucked up my settings were and he made a whole gif just to show
Like he met he's like, this is what your settings look like and this is what they should have looked like and I was like, oh my god
This was horrible now. I'm HD. Hold on. I want to look at my own stream
Let me on 70 20, let's put myself in 1080
I
Need a refresh the screen
It's still not as crisp as I would like but I don't really know about that
It does look a lot better than before. That's for sure
That's that's a fact. Why is the top of my head glowing? I
Don't understand. It doesn't matter, but I do look better. I look much better than before. That's that's that's the truth
I
Enhanced beauty
Enhance, but yeah, that was the first time my dad had actually seen my model. I
Never showed him it in him it yet. I also showed my parents
Strawny and Emmys
Shorts and my my parents were cracking up at Strawny's voice and like I was showing them clips from the the golf it collab of
Strawny trying to like
Distract me with the Scotland thing and my parents were dying and then I showed my mom
Emmys most recent short of like the voice thing and how and during the short when she's playing like
Poppy's playground. She's just like
Then my mom absolutely lost it. She just like it was so funny
Well, and I was it was really cool being able to show off like my gen mates to my parents
And they were also like just super impressed with Emmys voice acting and my my dad thought
Amy was me because like because he wasn't looking at my screen
I was showing the short to my mom
And he's like wow you guys sound alike. I'm like a little bit. This is the tiniest bit
I have my moments where me and Amy sound the same and I know like I think mercy and is there when we've all been in a
Call together. I was like wait, who's talking?
Because I I have a deeper voice
And I'm like, no, I can't I can't I can't do the same thing as Amy
But she my parents are super super impressed in me getting adopted perhaps
I don't know. I have to again when my parents come back from their vacation. They're going they're going to the beach for a week
I think I'll be like the last vacation that they go on for a while because my mom currently doesn't have a job
so they're like, you know trying to save and stuff and I
Want to do the like the guessing vTubers names things
And I'll start with my gen mates first and then I'll probably take like some submissions from you guys of people
That I want them to guess
But yeah
Are you getting more time than you? Yeah true. My parents are already darker than me. I
Was like look I'm tan now and they're like wow barely just like yourself and I'm like oh
I can't even win with my own parents
please
Yeah, yeah, oh my nose is itchy
Well, yeah, I'll play I'll play Elden Ring for a little bit
because I'm now I'm suddenly having FOMO of the girls being in the
The discord and I'm kind of now want to hang out with them too
Cuz we don't get to hang out that often we literally are like it's literally only for collabs or
Like if we have a group meeting
Because um, what's it called?
Cuz all about time zones and just like schedules and stuff it can be pretty difficult
So I try to make sure I get as much time with them as possible
But yeah
Oh
This is working fine. I'm very glad I was like you might get hope it's not my computer or my cable. That's not working
Veiler unity facts, of course the FOMO affects me too. I'm someone who always wants to be included
I don't have any friends my parents are like so what have you been up to and I'm like
Streaming and they're like, okay. What else I'm like
Recording and my mom's just like, okay. What else I thought you said it was your day off today and I'm like I recorded
Jesus like
What happened to your friends? Where are Salem and olive and I'm like, they're busy
Olive is getting married and so she's really busy with that
And Salem's busy with her own family. So I'm just like sitting here with no friends
So I'm going to only hang out with my gen mates and you guys
I have nothing else to do
And my parents are gone and my parents have been more busy hanging out with their own friends than me
Apparently they went to a luau and they went on a boat with their friends
um
The other day and I'm like, yo, what the hell is happening and they're like, oh, we brought you food
and then they gave me like a bunch of pot stickers and I'm like, wow, this is delicious. Thank you and um
My mom handed me a mic's hard lemonade and she's like take this with you and I'm like, okay, thanks
So maybe I'll drink that mic's hard lemonade
I don't have a little tipsy elden ring stream
um
But yeah, my parents my parents are in high demands
They are in high demands. They're always they're always doing stuff
I think my mom today is going to see off some family friends because they're moving to australia and I'm like, oh my god
What if they're moving your straw knee? Oh my god, I'll be sick. Um
But uh, yeah, my parents are like
They stay busy. I'm like, you guys are too. Why are you?
Why are people your age? You're so old. They're not old. They're they're they're not old at all
Uh, stop like having activities like you're supposed to be on your butt doing nothing all day at your age
But you're going out and doing stuff like actual great members of society
Like you're supposed to have no life like me. I'm kind of mad
Um
And then I get fomo where my parents are like, oh, he went to a luau and I was like
And I wasn't invited. They're like, oh, you wouldn't have liked it. I'm like, yes, I would. I love free food
Um
If it's still the stream of my heavenly presence, welcome. Welcome. Welcome and everybody. Yeah, straw knee streaming at the same time as me
I don't know what she's streaming
Um at the she was like before the meeting ever. She's like, uh, all right
I got to go I got to go fart on the roof lens eyelashes real quick and I'm like
I got to go fart on herms buddha shakes in a moment
So I got to go too
um
If they did nothing, but yeah, that's true my parents my grandparents my grandparents my parents are like, no don't have kids
This this this economy sucks
I'm like, don't don't don't we don't really care. We don't
We don't really care about that. I'm like facts. Thank you because children. No, thank you
Uh children are cool. I like kids. I'm very good with kids, but having a child of my own
No
No, thanks
Not that I wouldn't take great care of this and I feel like I'm digging myself a hole. Let me just stop talking
You're like, wow, she be hates children. She'll kill the children like she kills her tamagotchi
No, my tamagotchi, by the way, I was like playing with it during the meeting
This tamagotchi sucks. It doesn't want to do anything. Every time I give it an activity to do
It doesn't like the activity. I spent
400 tamagotchi points to get it a coloring book and it was like f this coloring book and then threw it and I was like
Bro, I've actually been paying attention to you despite you
being ugly
Let me see what's its status. Uh, oh, it's actually pretty happy right now. Let me
I also bought it more stuff and it doesn't anything I like give to like keep it like
Attention like to have like fun. It doesn't care. I gave it a stuffed animal. It was like nah
It likes to play. I think it just likes only sports stuff. I'm not quite sure
Can I ask your parents if no?
That's terrible
That's why would you say that?
That's not nice. That's inappropriate
I feel I feel but you know what?
You're getting caught for that
Getting caught. I can't you're lucky. Oh
animals
Go go go go and time out. That's not nice. Don't don't do that
Anyways, here's the ways I hate my tamagotchi. Get shot. Don't salute them
Um
It's over. She's picking us up on but I don't think I have the power to pick off like the 80 of you that are in here
or however many I don't look at the
viewer account because it makes me anxious
I just assume I'm always
I'm like, I just pretend I'm just streaming to 15 people and it makes me feel better
Although I know there's more than that and I appreciate all my lurkers that don't talk as much. Hello lurkers. You are loved
Yes, you kisses
um
But y'all it's like why do I blink like I'm
Like I'm a freaking bug
What's up with that? Why is my blinking tracking? No working properly?
I'm winking
Always lurking. Hey, I'm taken. That's fine
That's fine. We got shouted. I like all the lurkers get mentioned. They all come out of the woodwork and they're like, hi
I'm here. Yeah, that's me. I'm the lurker. She's talking about me. Oh me
Yes, you did I eat yet? Yeah, I ate. I'm fine. Don't worry
Madam as a lizard for yeah lizard lizard blink
Um
Oh semi-lurker. No, you're not you talk so often. What are you talking about?
But yeah, it was really nice hanging out with my parents last night. I got some tomatoes
Some cherry tomatoes and then I got some green beans and then my mom gave me a spaghetti squash that she had grown earlier
And she used this like she hands it to me. She's like, don't worry about the brown stuff
bugs just walk all over it and I'm like
Why would you tell me that?
And my dad's like, yeah, they poop and I'm like, why I'm gonna wash it anyways
But why do you hand it to me and say the brown stuff is from bugs walking all over the vegetable? I don't
She's like, it's organic
And then she proceeds to tell me how she threw away the two heads of cabbage that she grew
Because she was so grossed out from the slug poop in the slugs that were in them because slugs lovely green
And then I laughed at her because when we went outside
Uh, she stepped on a slug and the slug just slimed all over her toe and it was funny
And then my dad proceeded to say that she eats slugs. My dad is terrified of slugs. They're her he's he's
such a baby
I asked my dad if he wants to like I was telling my parents
I'm like, I have nobody to see alien romulus with like all my friends are busy
Nobody wants to see it and my mom looks over to my dad and she's like, oh
Your dad will probably see it with you and I'm like, no dad's a pussy
I said this verbatim. I'm like, no dad's a pussy. He won't see it
He was screaming in at the Deadpool Wolverine movie because like came in as a trailer
Hi, Mari. Mari is nori everybody. Ma nori is now Mari
um
And so I was like making fun of him. I'm like, no, he'd probably start screaming like a girl
During the during the movie because you guys heard my dad's high-pitched voice that I was like, ha like that's you always have my dad says hello
ha
And he'll always do that ha ha from like uh, nelson from
to simpsons
Uh, yeah, no, I'm gonna call my dad out and then he started I was making fun of my dad
And I said I was like calling him out and stuff
And then he started then he started talking to me in krayle that he knows I can't understand
He's like, oh, oh, oh, and then he started like insulting me in krayle and be like just you wait
Just you wait essentially in krayle
Um, and I'm like whatever whatever you can't even say it in english, bro. You can't even say it in english
You can't even say it in english. Say it to my face
My mom's just laughing. I don't mean my mom doesn't know any krayle either. So we're both just sitting there like idiots
My dad's just like speaking krayle
cursing us cursing our existence
um
Yeah, that's that that's a Haitian guilt for you. My dad lays on that Haitian guilt hard
I don't text him for a day. He's like, oh
Oh, my daughter. Where have you been? I thought you had forsaken me and I'm like shut up
Who are you my grandfather? Stop stop this enough. Stop it
I forgot you're kind of black like
No, sorry, fuck
um
Should I call the grandfather and say his krayles wax facts
I know my dad I asked my dad, you know the one time I asked my dad to teach me krayle
He just handed me a krayle dictionary. It was like here you go
and I'm like
What?
Qua
Esquise that qua that's not gonna help me. That's a fucking dictionary bro
He gave you all the words let's see a shit
He's like you got this and I'm like I want you to speak it with me around that house
Because like I knew a lot more when I was younger because my grandparents lived close to us
They were like 15 minutes away
So I had to go over my grandparents house and I'd be able to speak a little krayle
With my grandparents and my great-grandmother who's still alive at the time and then when they moved away to florida
I couldn't speak to anyone and then we weren't um my other Haitian cousins were like far away in the city. So we couldn't um
I couldn't talk to them that often
So, yeah
Am I free for now
For now also krayle is very interesting because it's all uh phonetically spelled. Uh, krayle didn't have a written language
I believe until like the 1980s
Very recently or something or like 1950s 60s or whatever. I can't recall
um
Because it was just it was just just a spoken language. It was never really written down and so
And that was an old dictionary too. So it's probably freaking inaccurate. I don't even I still have it. I don't know if I do
Um
Casting sheep, that's not the same thing. I'm not caging
I'm not caging krayle
Oh, I'm about to make a name for myself here
I've lost the casters fan. Oh, that's too bad
That's too bad. I know I want to I need to learn a language guys. That's that's my goal
It was one of my goals in my debut was to learn another language
I think I think I might learn Spanish
I'll get I'll get Mari to teach me Spanish. No, she probably gets sick of me during
Pregame yeah
Yeah, gotcha. Yeah
Yeah, my dad used to know french and um krayle, but now he only really knows um
Krayle in English
Because he didn't really speak
He didn't really speak a lot
Of french what rena? No, go away rena. You've been on my lap all morning
shoe
How sound does sound okay that sound too loud is the background music too loud
Madame she she by she be madame she be
Okay, cool
Geez louise. It's okay. All right. Geez louise. All right fine them
Main menus already. So you're right. We're the
What the fuck am I wearing?
I'm a fashion travesty. What was I doing? I was
I swear there's a dude that I was gonna fight
Where is he?
Who are you?
You're fighting. Yeah. No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah
I have to remember how to play
Wow
Okay, there's a little thing right there. That's great
I don't know which way i'm going
No, I was just yapping
I like the blue flames
I have cat hair in my eye
Oh my god. It's all over my glasses
My eye is no twitching
Nice lovely. Oh
Needle Knight Lita
Are you wearing the same? Is she also a carrion knight soldier?
Should I just fight her? The chat's frozen on screen. What's new?
What is new?
What's new the chat's always frozen
Oh
Walk in how am I supposed to walk in I just started I don't remember how to play
Cool, cool. I'm not fat rolling. So it's fine. Uh, what is this Ranala Ranila?
Ra wralt ran Ranila Ranella, what the fuck Georgia or Martin needs to stop
Hey, what's up queen?
Rolanna. I wish I had a horse
Oh
Oh, you're you have the same kind of moveset as like, um, what's her face?
I forget uh
millennia
Well nothing I use is going to work against you go on oh that's a thing I
forgot about that I knew if I know her moveset kind of I was locked in the
animation what's her poise like is it a shit as her sisters I don't know I need
another I might just have to get what the fuck I might just have to get blood
build up here oh oh never mind
we believe in you 1070 Chad is my thing freaking out is my extreme weight
freaking out hers is way better okay my still nice and crispy do you see that
post where someone might mind her model from the files and find out she had a
10 bendable that's so weird that's so random Katana you're not gonna break it
much yes I have a 1070 my I have such bad connection right now am I lagging I
can't tell since everybody's gonna be right let's see let's feel my computer
right now I don't hear it it's not bad she sounds okay no lag it looks like
because it says I have a lot of drop frames actually no I leave it's like
well OBS it goes yellow and red then green um during the rest of the boss
fight what oh that's fine I don't really have any other weapons should I fight
her right now or should I wait like I might just I might just get her a
couple of times I might just attempt a couple of times why do you cast right
now oh why do you cast it twice that's not nice oh you're too fast I would need
I need I I think I need another planet but what the fuck did you see her sword
clip it looks like she lost it and floated in the air what the hell she's
skippable yeah okay um I don't think I'm gonna fight her right now because I
literally am all carrying armored carrying thing carrying out and that's
not gonna affect her at all unless I just like hammer away at her but I'm not
good enough of a Eldering Player to do that to be honest with you because I
need like some hard hits because she means she moves really fast she moves
fast I would have to do probably some sort of distance on her immaculate fit
thank you fuck yeah um cuz yeah she's over there I might skip her for now and
come back
yeah carrying ours good cuz yeah that's a good man my weapon not so much I
haven't gotten any different weapons where am I going I don't know where I'm
going
Rolana seems easy to cheese oh hello brother what the shippity why is there
a crucible night right here why can't I like why can't I use any of my shit the
fuck yeah and I don't have any upgrade stuff
oh can I crouch
you can heal you motherfucker my nose is a G hold on my nose is a G
ow ow my nose is still itchy ow I might just die here cuz I can't stop
scratching my nose can I kill you like this I can't come on fall follow me
motherfucker I don't know if they did I don't think they did
should heal
I was hoping you fell off you bitch oh bro oh my god oh damn it oh fuck me oh that
was so funny I should have killed him when he was healing to be honest cuz if
you cuz I could have killed him in the animation but I was honestly so confused
as to what it was doing at first I was like what is it oh it's healing I should
I should have definitely killed it when it was on the healing phase oh yeah
almost got me there yeah almost got me you're thinking a real cheeky ain't ya
yeah thank you a real cheeky
I wish I had some like poison mist or something to sprinkle it with be like
ooh get get poisoned but I didn't do any of that shit I literally just sped run
all the way to the DLC cuz I just wanted to okay let's do this
ow oh fuck oh I jumped into that I thought I was gonna jump past it let's go
whoa whoa whoa you want you want to dance you want a tango you want to oh oh
oh you do that twice I thought you were gonna do it once and then I was gonna
parry oh act a little bit awkward except it's not technically a parry but you
know what I mean and this is a little bit of words it's fine though we will
continue we will pass every I might just run past him because I don't I don't
feel like fighting bosses for five minutes and dying and then going back
bonk
look how nice and tubby I am I'm like the tubbiest tub that ever tubbed before
god damn I'm fucking thickums thicker than a snicka yeah and I went down down
down the ring of fire the ring of fire and it burns burns burns oh
oh oh oh
why is it anytime I fight like a little mini boss or a boss this isn't even a
mini boss it's just a dude I just like I fucking destroy in my first time but
I just overthink the next times and then I can't even fight them anymore
bup bup bup bup that's the guy that's country music
well that's different Johnny Cash is a different breed it's not like I fuck my
car and then I cried cuz my woman left me and then I died inside and I love my
truck my truck fits all I need like I don't I don't like that me that means
up to music
that's fair no one yeah yeah exactly oh back up why how I need to roll to the
side not backwards okay they usually have an opening when they're going to
attack
okay twice shield back up one more time there we go you just got a lock fuck you
no cool helm die die potato not today all right what's this is anybody gonna pop
out I don't trust Liza P did something to me I's a P they have people just jump
out at you all the time imbued sword key why is there just a thing oh I thought
that was like the bulls on fire I was like that's not very safe is it
dolly part in facts is Fleetwood Matt consider country I don't think so it's
like soft rock that's what your dick is got him where the fuck am I going
anyways hello are you sitting over there then let me just creep but creep but
I'm creeping up to you thought your patches for a second creeping creeping
creeping they're all just hanging I missed I just knock you off
is there anything down there that I need only that or any of them coming up
here that one is I'll kind of let them actually come up here what the dog to
come up here whoa oh there's two dogs oh there's two dogs oh there's two dogs
oh there's two dogs oh there's two dogs and I need to heal oh excuse me pardon
I will be right with you expeditiously hold on let me just pardon I don't
appreciate please can you get your dog please sir I'm so sorry to kill it now
I don't need the stance coming from you because I'm gonna break it just like that
oh take that sword baby girl yeah just like that who's a good discord kitten
all right your next motherfucker taste my metal superhero landing ah no not very
nice my nose is itchy again so I'm just gonna spare our one is there somebody
else no what the dog do when I got that dog with me whoof bar bar I got
smithing stone sick what's this a somber smithing stone very somber very sad
indeed outplayed yeah take take my sword let me heal
yeah did it what the shibbity something's in my nose hey um can I talk to you
about our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ no well he died first since impaled on
the cross much like you just weren't paled on my cock right now sorry am I
the fat bastard is that who I am then I'm a fat bastard then holy shit
erm oh I knew it I heard some sparkly do does somewhere I see you motherfucker
you're lucky you can't reach me and I can't reach you electric boogaloo can
hit me from here no you can't uh who's that guy pointing at hey you good
stop whispering all weird can I kill you I miss tuple can play at this fucking
game yeah that's what I thought what it hey need some milk can I just can I take
you with me I've always wanted my own dead body my mom said I can never have
one but you know I have her right I can get my own dead body anytime I want I
can't bring you with me I can make you dance a little bit dance for me why mca I
just found out yes like yesterday that the YMCA songs about giving guys guys
giving each other blowjobs and I did not know I did not know that was a gay
anthem YMCA did you guys know that I did I just got over that recently hello hello
oh fuck
a taste of your own medicine then fuck a taste of your own medicine then oh fuck
there's two of you hi yeah oh fuck I missed oh I'm out don't kill me don't kill
me I'm stuck at the door I'm stuck at the door I'm stuck at the door
they're done they're done I just needed to heal all right now I'm ready for you
oh I'm out of fuck it's fine who are you attacking brother oh fuck mother fucker
oh yeah you block that that's fine let's go queen oh oh yeah I get hit oh get
the blood damage oh oh is your period I'm gonna call you my little catch a
packet my little gusher oh yeah anyways um hello why I have this room if
there's nothing important in it other song in the Navy no I knew it was a gay
anthem of the blue bit no it's not apparently it is what what do you mean
Jesus Christ why Jesus Christing me so don't give me that look don't give me
that look give me that look excuse me he's a hell of a guy I mean my mom my
like Pelican fly I mean you're so shy and I'm loving you tie and I'm good
thank you the guy that I think I was all right yeah hey oh wait I just looped
back around yes I did yes I did please tell us if I is this is where I came
from did I go in the wrong direction this is where I came from cuz I was
looking for this motherfucker what I'm going back
boomie is under my chair hello boomerton everybody's dead so we're fine
this is absolutely terrible there's a spell around there how would I spell
these nuts across your face oh got him got him absolutely body then go him get
caught got up so this was not going before I don't recall another smithing
stone well must fell off because I was looking at chat fuck you guys you guys
distracted me how dare you how dare you distract all right so then I go up
who the fuck is shooting at me I hear it I'll kill them eventually
all right and then we went up here to Rolana was there no other way to go
besides maybe out this door question mark yeah destroy those chairs I think
that was it bros
not yeah okay what oh that's my sword I was like why is there a dude right there
the sort it's fucking me I'm such a dumbass um all right probably not until I
kill her all right let's go over the bridge jump yeah oh shit I didn't think
that was actually gonna do anything all right nice you
up the stairs up the stairs up the stairs up the stairs up the stairs up the
stairs up the stairs we are going up the stairs we are going across the bridge
we are going cross the bridge we are going across the rocks we are looking
at these cooks we are jumping on the rocks we have something
what
Is it up there?
There's a lot, huh? Okay, I missed that I'm a little bit doffed if you will. Oh
That's a ladder. What the fuck I can't tell look at it. It's like fucking invisible. It's an invisible ladder
What is that?
Since when do they do that in this game they like turn slightly invisible
When you look directly at them, I don't understand
Hey, yeah, then oh you yippie-ki-yay motherfucker
Ash of war I don't care about no stupid ash of war. I barely use my own ash of war
I am there's a giant spider outside my window. It's an orb we've huh
One of the best ashes of war in the game
Oh
It's always on that oh, I may be I'm just dumb a la la la
Let's see then where should we go after this?
How's the Elden Ringing it's it's ringing right quite quite well if you will ringing quite well
Ringing quite well indeed
Let me just
There you go. Okay, my things real quick
Odin excuse
Got some spirits grave stones here for what's have a reason are you winning?
Yeah, I just I beat our Rolaina for Lana Rodana Romana Ramanos, where are my fucking things
Is it above me, oh, thank God, I was gonna say I'm like if it's down there. I'm committing suicide all
I'm so sorry if I screamed and terrified anybody who just had me all in the background
If you're working right now
Welcome to she be caught in bomb radio where you hear me
Shit talk some Elden Ring NPCs, although they're way better than I am even though they're AI
Oh
Yes, my whole 30 K runes, when did I get 30 K runes? I don't really recall that to be honest with you. Yeah
All right, let's take a peek so we're here we kind of went around here. There's more
What the hell Jesus fuck. Oh, yeah, I already went over there because I beat that
Oh, there is a map
Can I get there without
Cuz then maybe if I
If I go up and then down and there I can get the map yes question mark
It's complicated
Explain explain yourself
Because it looks like I could just go up and around and then down in here and then in there I
Finally get the piece of cat hair out of my nose. Let's make it be rub it
You can get to the map without any bosses right now explain
Because I'm I'm going to go over here and then go across
No, not that way, what do you mean
What do you mean
It's hidden me and my friends had a look it up
What
I
Don't know if I trust you
It's below we'll figure I'll figure it out. No, I won't but we'll try
I'll try I'm smart ish
Not really
Am I going the right way? I am
I'm a little slow. I'm just a wee bit slow
It's from the castle I was in
Well, I want to explore this way anyways
So then
If I go fuck
If I go like a little bit is over here
A little bit down. Oh my god, cat food dispenser my beloved you scared me
Nope wrong way, yeah
Let's see, what the fuck are you? Oh, I thought it would look like red guy in a horse for a second. I
Just want to see what's over here. Oh, hello. It's you. That's right
No, I'm in water, how do I not be in water to go back up
Boomi finally get doll, please. I'm gonna feed via in a second. I'll put her in my lap and chat with you guys as you
Can hear her munch and crunch
Oh look look at this fascinating perfect. Oh, that's so cool. What the hell
Oh
Why is this game so gorgeous, I'm just gonna rest and I'm gonna go get
feel
Tear off my take off my headphones real quick lack. I'm gonna tuck in my controller so it doesn't fall
Okay, let me grab a little baby
Oh
Massive this shit today her poop was human-sized and it was bigger than my own
Her body struggles a little bit to like move poop out so it takes her like a couple days to poop and they're just
I'm putting that on my desk before I grab Berr
To do do do do do do-do go-do-do-do
All right come here cute daddy
Now she's in my lap okay get fed get fed
Hey, nice to meet you. She's like little
breathy purrs. Would you like some food? Come on. Eat into the mic for us.
Do you hear her crunches? You're pushing food out of the bowl.
Here's some cat ASMR for you. Yeah before I had to feed oh that was crazy
lightning I just saw out my window and it flashed through my entire house.
Did you hear the thunder? Holy shit. My god. That was free as stomach now. Cat and thunder
ASMR weird combination but it works. ASMR cat chewing thunder. But Afea used to only be a liquid
but now she's a lot more stronger that she can eat um kibble by herself and also drink water by
herself without me having to syringe it into her mouth. So I'm quite happy. Now she crunch.
So how uh how are you guys doing? Thunder thunder thunder cat.
She's so funny when she eats. I literally have her held like a baby in her food on her chest.
Not like it's again it's in a food bowl and she's just helping herself to it.
Are they still in the discord?
They are. And Azura's streaming. Oh whoa Azura what are you streaming there? Azura's been working on
some some some stuff and uh ooh bleeding hearts are in for a tree that's all I'll say.
Maybe you don't remind you of thunder cats why?
Use some game programming cool for the for for what kind of game?
I think our game is being finished up from what we were talking about in the meeting. It's
like a couple more things. Afea you've knocked out all the food and now it's on you. Hold on let me
just let me just I'm sorry to take your food away for a second but it's like all in the blanket.
Let me just do that. There we go. Let me tuck you in like a little little papoos my little papoos
and here you go now you can have it back.
Got back from doing some grocery shopping nice nice.
I don't know if you can also hear one of the cats eating in the background.
That was some crazy thunder. It's like one giant thunder cloud is above me right now.
Working cool. Feel their fan game oh nice cool.
Do what you can. I can't wait to play it when you when you finish.
Bye bye have a good one. You went to a car you should have taken a day off you always had time to
rest after those things.
Oh we got more mods. Just got a notification for that.
Yeah it's really cool. I like that it's Castlevania-esque. I really think it fits us.
I could see like um mercy like throwing like the uh like the scissors as like some sort of like
like the metal cross that one of the characters throw. You watched the Halloween concert was
a fun yeah that's awesome. It looked great I've seen a couple of clips but I haven't I haven't watched
it myself. It must have been super fun conceptualizing that.
Lurkers I hope you're having a good day too. Don't don't think I forgot about you.
I care about you too and how your day's going. You don't have to say anything but I hope you had a good day.
The girls served hard. What did they serve? Do they serve cunt?
Do they serve? They really served.
Face concert was cool. Yeah I heard the face concert was cool. It's cool that they were
able to have their own concert in New York like that.
She be mercy or probably a martial character is her enemy mystic. Embrace monster girl vibes
or icy and no idea what to do with strongy. Hmm yeah that's tough. You could probably do monster
girl with strongy too just so everything's balanced you know. It was very loud in person crowd got
it oh yeah but oh yeah Mint was part of that. I love how Mint is just like in everybody every
company. She's just like I'm hanging out with you Shoujo now hanging out with Faze now I'm hanging
out with these people now I'm hanging out I just I like that that's so fun. It's cool it's foster so
many connections like that. Come on Fia come on come on ma'am sometimes like she wants me to
rotate from eating from my hand and eating in the bowl so now I can tell I feel like she
wants to eat from my hand then sometimes she accidentally bites me she doesn't mean to but
it's funny here ma'am ma'am you did eat a lot this morning so do you want this are you done
can I kiss you I gave her kisses and then she started eating she was waiting for kisses
and she no that that won't happen I don't think she would ever want to join us that's very sweet
though I would like to that'd be cool to hang out with her at some point but that's very very
distant very distant although I know strongy's rated her a couple times and she's been very
thankful for it so I think that's sweet she's very cute enough to get away with munching on
she doesn't mean to she's aiming for the food and she can't really like aim that well do you
know cats can't really see that close in front of their face they have really bad eyesight they're
good with seeing far but not close and so sometimes she'll just miss like a snake like I want snakes
try to get something and it looks goofy good girl for you
I can hear smacking her lips against my my little palm on my hand let me get you some more
here you go
good girl
get munched on get munched on
cat's perception is a little sped up oh yeah yeah they have like an insane reaction time
doesn't stop me from playing with boomi I don't care if he's faster than me
I am the ultimate I'm the apex predator I'm the alpha male
it's funny boomi does a hop like he'll like aim to like rub against my leg but
it's a whole like hop to rub against my leg but he'll miss and so he just says he's hop
he just hops excitedly in the air now and he gets a little like bashful when I laugh at him
because but it's like super cute here you go ma'am
no you knocked that on the floor that's fine boomi will probably eat it
ooh big chomp he's a good big chomp
hi boomi boomi's on my desk boomi this is the same food there's more food in your bowl that you
did not finish yet
my cats stick their paws in the water before that to test the depth and I'm like can you
guys not do that like you're putting your gross paws in there and then the water is probably bad
oh it's raining it's raining hopefully my power doesn't go out like before
go on boomi go away let your sister eat jeez bro
I didn't know it was gonna rain today
it's funny I noticed boomi like I recently noticed boomi does something he'll dig his paw like he'll
like you know how a cat will like dig when it's um about to eat like using the litter box and
stuff or like dig at something um boomi when he's drinking water he'll dig the ground with
both his front paws almost like he's making biscuits but not like he'll just like move his paws around
while he's drinking and I noticed that reason I'm like since when do you do that why are you
why are you like why are you doing a little dance when you're drinking water are you just like
real excited or it's really cute like you look he kicks his little front paws back and he's like
water
it's as if you are like drinking from a cup of water
and then oh your cat does that too oh my gosh okay I'm like is something wrong with him um
boomi did you just put litter in that water why are you looking at me like that um
and it's like if we were drinking like from a boat like a bowl of like cereal and then and we
put our hands in front of the cereal bowl then we started like digging in front of it but also
like drinking the milk no hands he is adorable when he's not being a menace he was very cute this morning
hi can I give you a kiss oh yeah give you a little forehead kiss do you like the forehead kiss
mister he'll stay still for a forehead kiss he loves getting headpats and forehead kisses
isn't that right he's a boy hello oh oh I took another one I took another forehead kiss
you want this last kibble you're missing you're just looking my hand get that one
get it nope fia you just knocked it on the floor that's fine you're done boomi there's nothing in the
bowl there's nothing in it can you move so I can get the water to fia please
here you go ma'am
oop I just spilled it on myself it's fine
accidentally overfilled this bowl
hold on I need a position that's better
boomi it's water it's nothing special about it
there you go fia now you'll be able to drink easier
here excuse me boomi move your butt cheeks out of the way here you go
she's swarping she also like sucks her mouth sometimes when she's drinking water
oops
I have to wash my hands out for this.
Go on, keep drinking.
Go on, bud.
Oi oi.
Keep drinking.
Are you done?
Don't sniff the mic.
Your face is all wet.
It's kind of funny.
Are you sniffing the mic so intently?
Ma'am, please finish drinking water.
Are you done drinking water?
I think she's done drinking water because now she's just more interested in the microphone
if you can hear her moving against it and sniffing.
Okay.
Now we put you down.
Not like that.
Fall down for a nap, then.
What are you doing with me?
That's a wild rain.
Perfect for walking all four of you.
You might be able to hear it outside my window because my desk is right next to my window.
Can't you see?
No.
I didn't mean that.
Comfy rain.
Comfy rain noises.
Stretch my back.
Oh my God.
Can I put my headphones back on and get cosy?
Rain to soothe the soul indeed.
To soothe.
For soothe.
Rain sounds to reduce the...
That's funny.
What the heck?
Come on, Elvin Rain.
There we go.
Can you guys hear the rain sounds?
Cos I think I can hear them in my microphone.
Yeah?
Oh, cool.
Okay.
Cos I'm like, why does it sound like it's raining in game?
Cos I have a monitor on.
I didn't think it was that loud, my God.
This also could be my AC.
Yeah, or it's the wind sounds and Elvin Rain, I don't know.
Okay.
Oh, there's my controller.
Might be the game.
Over there.
To...
It's flying to me.
Thank you for the remember.
I didn't think it was such a steep drop.
I should have never doubted y'all.
Apologies.
Can I go around this way and under?
Maybe.
Very, very steep drop that one is.
Oh, it's raining in game.
How fitting.
Let me just...
Oh, did I already get rid of that?
Around the side.
Let us comment.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Not that close.
Excuse me.
Dead bodies.
Thank you.
I'm stuck.
Torn, please.
Hallelujah.
Where am I?
Okay.
Keep going.
Yeah.
That's where I came from.
Now I see what you guys meant.
Oh, my God.
What the hell?
Okay.
No, I'm too.
I need to, like, go more over here.
Please don't fall the fuck off self.
All right.
What was that?
Hold on.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Torn it for the love of God.
Ow.
See, that's what happens to it.
That's what happens when you act up.
All right.
Is there anything over here?
Anything to fasten that in now?
It's just a wall.
Just a wall.
All right.
This is pretty nice.
Layers like an onion.
Understandable.
Very beautiful, dark forest.
It looks like there is a cave nearby.
All right.
Is there two?
What the heck?
Hold on here.
Oh, not these motherfuckers.
No.
Why is it so dark?
I cannot say shit.
What the hell?
Hold on.
I need to think.
Let me think.
Aw, I'm being aggroed and I can't look at the...
Oh, my God.
I wanted to look at the map.
This isn't even the darkest, for I'm running into the wall.
Oh, what the hell is that?
Hold on.
Let me just think for a sec.
All right.
Hug the wall.
All roads lead to here.
Please.
Sorry, bear.
I am in the middle of something.
How, bitch?
Oh, you're so fucking stupid.
Thank you.
Was there another way around?
They have to go this way.
Is it much darker in creepy or forest?
Yeah, I also had a lot less HP than I thought as well.
Let's do a little exploring then.
Two's over here.
I think it's just a dungeon.
Well, do all roads just simply lead to the dungeon?
I can't go around that.
Let's see.
I think that's the case.
Do I come out on the other side from the dungeon?
Probably, right?
I just go deeper into the earth?
No?
Should we go?
Is this worth it?
Should we go down this dungeon, boys?
I'm being aggroed.
What the fuck?
How did those not get me?
Well, grift cats, it comes.
Yeah, do it.
All dungeons are right.
All right, we'll do it.
Let's get rid of these.
Fuck you.
I'll come back to you later.
All right, let's...
A weapon?
Oh, great.
Something I can't use.
I love that for me.
I bet I could have jumped on top there.
I bet there's something over there.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
What the fuck are you?
Hello?
What?
Oh, my God.
The gremlins here look real creepy.
I don't like that it jumps at me.
There's one over there.
Come on, then.
Is this why you guys wanted me to go here?
Is this why?
Is this why you said, oh, I want you to go?
Is this timed?
Ow.
Ow, please don't kill me.
I'll kill you, though.
Oh, nice.
I don't think I really need that right now.
What the fuck?
Why isn't there another one?
Can I jump on this?
I'm not going to try it.
Oh, I didn't drink that, but that actually still helped.
No.
Ghost flame, motherfucker.
What?
Interesting.
That's an interesting spell, because it does one big one,
and then, huh, fascinating in it.
Oh, I saw you coming from a mile away, bro.
A mile away.
What was that?
Why is there a fogger bloom in here?
I think I go up back and around at some point.
La la la.
I thought that was something on the ceiling.
Ow.
Oh, fuck, I didn't think it would hit me again.
Well.
Oh, you're closer.
I'm looking at chat.
I'm not paying attention to you at all.
That didn't work.
Can you come a little bit closer?
Oh, fuck it, bro.
I'm so fucking stupid.
I'm going to die this guy spamming fireball.
Are you serious?
I'm going to literally cry.
I'm just going to literally just go attack him.
Do it.
Shut up.
That took away too many flasks, and I literally needed to.
All right.
Who's in here?
Who's going to jump out?
Fucking whore.
No.
Who else?
Is anybody else in here?
Oh, yeah, there you are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, that's nifty.
Some dragon shit.
I'm getting bonked by a burdo.
That's so true, though.
It literally looks like stone burdo.
Wait, is this where I came from?
It's a lot of vulgar blooms.
Yeah, that is where I came from.
Up, up, up, up, up.
Who else?
Okay.
Oh, fuck me.
This is a fun game.
This is a fun game, then.
Not resin.
Now where do I go?
Oh, over there.
Wee!
Oh.
Bitch.
It's me.
Hi.
I'm the problem.
It's me.
Oh, that didn't work.
Awkward.
That barely did anything to you.
Oh, what the?
I want this spell.
Whatever it is, I want it.
You're a weird-looking motherfucker, though.
You got a long head.
Long neck motherfucker right there.
I'm going to die.
I knew you were interested in that.
You got to check your fucking corners, like it's siege or something.
Or up top.
I'm waiting for someone to jump on me.
You know, the dude was up here, but still.
Who else?
Who else is here?
Okay, you.
Some full-guard bloom.
I'll take it.
Oh, there's two of yous.
Come on, then.
Probably shouldn't use such a powerful...
It's fine.
Oh, I can't.
I don't really have anything.
What?
Why?
What the fuck was that?
I couldn't lock on.
That was so weird.
It's fine.
I'll be back for it.
I'm just going to run.
Oh, yeah, those lads.
Those lads, then.
All right, let's zoom.
Now.
What the fuck?
All right, then.
Yoink.
Oh, fuck.
I went the wrong way.
I'm going to lose all my fucking yet.
Fuck, bro.
I couldn't.
I rolled out of the way.
It was not working out for me.
Oh, fuck me, bro.
This is only 50k.
It's not really a big deal.
If it was like 100, I'd be pissed.
Where am I?
Ow!
What the fuck?
Fuck off!
I'm just spamming R1.
You know, this is itchy.
Okay, which way was I going?
That's such a cool spell.
Okay, now I'm near them.
Whoa, I almost missed it.
Ow.
Did not mean to use my actual war on you.
I missed that.
That's fucking stupid.
Oh, my God, that spell is so powerful.
It's still going.
What the fuck?
I'm going to stream more?
Yeah, I'm going to stream more.
Yeah, the fat armor is helping.
I like how she sends forth a reflin.
Oh, I see him.
Oh, that motherfucker.
Okay, I'm glad that I kind of died because then I would have died anyways to him.
Can I bait one of you guys?
Come on, then.
I missed?
Why do I keep missing for you?
Don't kill me again.
Don't do it.
He is an insane poise.
Why is he so...
Why does it do with the axe so powerful?
Oh, my God.
Madam, shut up.
Oh, it's the battle.
That's right.
He buffed himself.
Fuck, I ran too fast.
I'm getting crushed like a pancake.
Oh, no.
Please stop.
Please, I'm too young.
I'm too young for this.
I'm too precious.
I'm too wholesome.
I can't stand these things.
I don't know how going this way, because I don't go up.
Is this still falling?
Oh, my God.
Is this shit behind me?
Oh, no.
Come on.
I'll hurry before it comes.
Let's take a moment.
Oh, that's why dungeons just hand me my ass, to be honest.
Oh, my God, my runes.
How crazy.
That's so wild.
You know, I'm going to do you first.
Come on, girly pop.
No, I'm not the both of you.
I don't want the both of you.
Oh, bitch.
Oh, I didn't think you were.
I thought you were staggered.
I thought I could have repossed you.
Hey, let's let's do.
I thought it matters.
I have the wrong physics on.
There's two of you.
What are you standing on?
I'm going to run and grab that.
I know he was standing in the fucking corner.
I'm just going to run in and grab that.
I don't even give a shit.
I know.
I know it's like a faith weapon, but whatever.
All right.
Let's go.
Zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom, zoom.
Oh.
Why is it?
What is even bouncing on?
How does it bounce on that?
Someone said it was a faith weapon.
He's doing tricks on it.
When he ride a dick, he's going to spell his name.
Fog, grift, catacombs.
Oh, I wish he wouldn't get aggroed so early.
Ow.
It slowed down because I was going to heal.
Hurry up.
What?
Okay.
Uh, fuck me then.
Did that thing follow me?
Oh, I was going to say.
Ah, fuck it.
I'm just using katana mode.
All right then.
Ow.
Did you drop a smith in stone?
Yeah.
Um, can I bait out the other guy first if I just crouch?
I'm going to bait him.
Stop crouching.
Oh, fuck me, brother.
Oh.
I'm out.
You think I can take him?
The riflings are coming!
Somebody sound the horns!
Looks like more yapping.
That's fine.
Never mind.
I'm like, should I show off for the riflings?
Well, they love me if I do this.
Cue me.
Do it.
All right.
Oh, oh, oh!
No, no!
No, like this!
It's not like this.
Ah!
I'm killing myself.
I'm killing.
I'm going to end...
Err...
Stop.
Stop it.
Do the ring around the rosy.
Pop a pot of posy, rare.
Do the ring around the...
Oh, fuck.
We do a pop a pot of...
Ah!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Motherfucker, just run.
You just fucking run.
I can't fucking play Elden Ring anyway.
Oh!
Zoom-zoom-zoomen
down my
heart me
Ta down to fall out me
Thinking of her can have it
da-da-da-da
No, no, no, no, no. Oh fuck. I'm dead
Hi reflings
Hello reflings
Hello, just down mr. President get down with it or bad self get down with your bad self then
Hello, it's me. She be caught on bomb
All right, uh, we got the bat we can leave
We did it. Yeah, I see Moe. We did it
We got our ass beat by four guys. We did it. We did it. We did it. Yeah
We look real chunky, but we look really nice. We did it. We did it. We did it. Yeah
There's a boss of the dungeon
There's a boss
What
Where's the boss I
Know there's always a boss that was that's why I was confused. I
Missed like half of it. It's a cool boss
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, I understand but where where after that you're not moment fuck off
go away um
Um boss is past the lads you're trying to five good how
Lower down
Lower boomies in front of my fucking screen. Hi, sir, his mouth is open. He's looking really doopy
Just explore under the spike trap. Oh
Yes, I noticed that cuz I'm like that's not the same spot because there's a dude there
Fuck it will go. Let me stop chewing on stuff. Big big man. You're really cute today
Don't don't be a menace
Don't be a menace. Don't be a menace. You're so big. Oh, you're so heavy. God damn. You're my arms crack. Okay, ready?
Uh
some
a human getting
So Bronstein sun protein supper teen super teenager pretend supper team supper team suffered fuck so we're fuck sugar fucking fuck up
Go, go go go go go. Go go go?
Roome trying to catch me riding dirty trying to catch me riding dirty my music soul
I'm I'm swaying in I just want your attention and love what stop stop
Go ow, it's fine
It's good
Glorious all right
Hello
We go deeper and deeper and deeper into the catacombs and we put on lantern just in case it's too dark in
Hello, why is there a stake America here?
Excuse me
Fuck you
Bad
Who else who else wants some who's under here. Oh, yeah, I'm not fucking stupid. I know how this game is played
Oh, I know how this game is played. I know how this game is played. I know how this game is played
Oh my god, there's two of them. Oh my god. I'm gonna get ganged. I'm getting ganged. I'm getting ganged
I got on walk on walk you motherfucker. Oh my god
Chat died you dead you died good. I don't care
That is not my priority. At least it's a stake America
Oof the frames oof the frames fuck off shush shut up. I don't care my bitrate was used to be at fucking
Whatever, I don't think that's what you're talking about, but I'm just gonna be an asshole
Oh
Where's the other one it's behind me. He's behind me, isn't he?
Wow, I was we read what the fuck
We raided she be and she was so mean to us she was so mean to us
It's cuz I'm raging at a game and I'm taking it out on you get spit on
Oh
What the hell why is this so huge it what the fuck
Brother do you really think that's gonna reach me what the hell excuse me
That's not how that fucking works, dude
That's not how this fucking works
That's not no. No, that's I don't I don't approve you both get it. How about that? Oh
My god. Oh my god. I'm getting rocked my shit's getting rocked. I should have
Healed before I attacked you, but it's fine. Hopefully there's nobody else in here. There isn't a slurp
Grape glove worked lovely
Uh
All right, so I'm assuming oh brother you're kidding me
Is it gonna fall as I run like oh
How's he casting so fucking many
Can you can you run out of uh, wow, can you fuck jam? What the hell?
Can you like please run out of stuff that would be great
I wish you could run out of spell juice like I can all right fuck it. We run out
All right, oh hi. Oh, this is like that fuck. No, don't do it. Don't don't don't don't don't don't be an ass don't
Bye
Anyways
So I started blasting um, where's the next one? Oh
Yeah, we're gonna do that
Yeah
Great great
Hey, we love to see it. Well, let's reach you. Okay, I did can you walk towards me because I don't trust that
My god, what the fuck is happening
All right, is anybody fucking else over there yeah, yeah, what is that a slug?
Motherfucking slug. What is this?
What are you?
Oh, you are a slug. Okay. I'm just gonna walk over you then. Sorry. I just got killed by a fucking slug, bro. I
Got killed by a fucking slug
That's not fair I don't think that's very nice. I don't think that's very appropriate. I don't think
I
Sorry, I just got noted from Neanna who like
Responded to one of my tweets of my dad role-playing as me as my model
No, oh, why did I go this way? What the fuck is wrong with me? Oh
Oh
Surprise
Are you serious
Oh
Slug tipped three dollars and thirty three cents. Oh cute bunny. I'll just give a little pokey-poke
I'll just give a little pokey-poke. I
Hate the imps bro in the main base game in this game. I'm like imps are my least favorite
In those things that look like worms
Little like blight thingies those things freak me the freak out. Okay, we just got a zoom
Ow, ow, ow, ow
It's fine
We're good
You're gonna run over to me. Oh my god
What are you doing? No, I can't I'm stuck. I was literally stuck. I couldn't move. I'm literally hitting buttons
Wait, wait, I want to see all the deleted messages
Why are you why are you muting this person this person didn't do anything wrong?
Please don't get trigger happy. Thank you
Mods stand down. I'll call I'll call shit out mods. Don't you fucking worry. Stand stand down, please
People are just saying lol. They can laugh at me. It's fine. I laugh at myself
I
Don't care about my ruins to be honest with you
What's this
I'm like, oh my god, there's so many. Oh my god, give me out of here. Give me out of here. Give me out of here
I
Fucking Pogo motherfucker
I swear a fucking god
You two bitch
You're all hoarsed to me
Shadow realm rune. Wow, that was worth it. That was so worth it. Wasn't it?
Can I bait that?
How am I supposed to run up there in time? I don't
Oh
What oh fuck
Hurt at her
Can we can we try this one more time?
Well, are you sure you can't do simple platforming?
Please okay, thank god
Thank you
What this then ash of war blink bolt
Um, is there anywhere else I can go
Besides down
All right, well, yeah, I kind of should I get my rooms I might get my rooms
My game sound is liking
No, I can't go off of that it's gonna hit me so close that was that was close
There's more up there
Oh
Why is this struggle?
What do I hear I hear something going on
Just thank you. Oh
What do you mean there's more up here if I like beat that you mean
Okay, it's making me fucking dizzy. Oh
My god, I'm gonna puke. Oh fuck me, bro. What the hell
Thank you to hear a oink stone sheath sword
Fascinating
Hey, what's that? Oh Christ shield
Straight sword strike I don't have enough strength for that
What the sigma
That I run around with half health doesn't bother you that much. Yeah, I'll say I'll sip it just for you
He'll madam. He'll
Is there more up up here
Oh my god see stuff up here fucking puke
Oh my god, I'm getting so fucking dizzy
Oh my god, I'm gonna fucking die help knowing my ass it slipped between the crack
Now I'm good, okay, we go down now we go down down in an early around sugar. We're going down swinging
Oh
How how do you get me? How do you get me?
How how I'm against a wall. I'm against a fucking wall
You shouldn't be able to fucking clip through the fucking wall. They're fucking fire. Fuck
Anyways
We take a sip of my coffee
See she would have died if you didn't you don't know that you don't fucking know that so I jump down
Okay, yo
Irma
What the shivity is this where what where am I going?
I
Should I go to the trap hole the trap should I should I
Now go across over there in the trap hole
Oh wait, I might have fucked up
Oh
Where am I going? What do you mean? Where am I going? I went the right way. Well, that's where I came from wasn't it?
Right I go that way I go down here. I was going the right way
Oh
Should I heal or should I just should I stay at half health?
But I kind of want to go in the trap hole
Incantate I don't really need an incantation should I
You guys have to tell me go south I'm fine
You know what I think I'm gonna I think I'm gonna carry on like this. I don't think I need this health. Oh
Okay, maybe I do
We stay bouncing, baby we stay bouncing
What the oh that scared me but I was like what is that? What is that?
Um it's something up there. I feel like I can't get you yet
Audio why are you clipping? I got a fish we go up. Oh
We're going down down in an early around and sugar. We're going down swinging. I'll be your number one with the bullet
Oh
Loaded gun stake America. Let's cock it and pull it. Oh, she actually has a head. Oh
Lore Lore she has a head
You guys ready you guys ready you guys ready hold on
Let's fucking go who the fuck are you death night? Oh
Fuck you're strong for no reason. Oh
Brother oh water
Okay, can I can I no please
Sir, please I am but a little girl. Oh
Eat that. Oh
My god, this will take me a while to get
Is this oh is this Godwin? Isn't that Godwin?
Yeah, it's fucking Godwin
Yeah, it's the mo crystal tier don't don't ask I I forgot to unequip it. It's fine
It's one of Godwin's nice, I remember I remember listening to this in the lore
Well, this isn't doing much against him maybe a little rock sling will do it let's try let's try a little bit of rock sling
No, oh that doesn't do jack shit
Oh, it has it has Godfrey's moveset. I'm pretty sure
Oh, that's a fucking sick thing the robber
Now
Oh
Face down do you feel better now as she come in a ground
Always prepared always prepared
Yeah, what the fuck how am I supposed to beat him? I
Might I might just uh, uh, what should I call it? I
might uh
Do a little bit of the ding-a-ling-a-ling
The ding-a-ling-a-ling bat-mang-a-ling-a-ling-a-ling-a-ling-a-ling can you go aggro him instead, please?
Fucking aggro him instead
Look at this motherfucker. Oh my god, it missed. I'm literally gonna kill myself
Oh
My god, I'm so close to death. I forgot to heal after I summoned him
Oh god, oh yes, brother. Yes, brother get him get him queen. Oh
No, oh, hello
Hello
What is that? Can I heal?
That was insane don't die. Oh
He took my health. Oh fuck. He took my health. Keep him staggered. Keep him staggered. Keep him keep him locked in
Keep him locked in keep him locked in get him get him blood
Sick of sick of
Sick of keep going
That's pretty cool. That's a pretty sick
That's pretty sick the grab is pretty sick. I'm not gonna lie to you that was pretty hot
Mmm, I was pretty sexy. I kind of like that
I'm gonna do that to you guys. I'm gonna pick you up and suck the life from you
Suck the soul out of your
Mmm, anyways
I'm gonna use those moves. I'm gonna learn
Okay, this is awkward. Let me just
Yeah, throw some rocks at him that'll that'll tell him that'll show him who's boss
Okay, don't let him get you though. You're a spirit Ashley. You should be fine now. That's fine. Don't worry about it
Oh, it's not fine. Oh
You staggered him. Yes. Yes, Queen. Oh not no Queen. No Queen. No, no Queen. This is not what we do here
No Queen. That's not that's not how it goes
Thanks, your soul is mine
I
Think Godwin's nice had originally been part of the crusade is an extension of Mesmer because Godwin cool like that
I believe that I believe that I believe Godwin to definitely help out his his brother like that, you know
He'd be like, you know, I'll help you on your crusade, but then he's like because his mom's just piece of shit, you know
Why are you throwing things at me at the rip? I
Can't roll fast enough. Oh my god. Oh my god. I'm gonna die
No mother fucker. I'm rolling too early. That's why that's what I'm doing. I'm spam rolling
Hey, um, hey, um, hey, uh, can you like?
Just like let me live I
Wish I wish go get him go get him in my stead brother
Go get him. I need
I need
You know what? I need I need a better weapon guys
I just desperately need a better weapon because I can't beat any fucking bosses
Like this like I'm just not strong enough. I
Can't I'm not skilled enough
To beat them I'm sweating my hands are sweaty nice weak arm spaghetti
No, no since when do you open with this since when do you open with that?
He's right behind me, isn't he oh
You bitch
It's better to not lock on him to be honest, can you get like we're both gonna fucking spam you how about that?
Yeah, you want to you want tango?
Get him get him sick him get fuck. I got caught on the fucking pole. No, you can't do that. It's not allowed
Get him get his ass get his ass. Oh god. Oh, I need a heal. I need to know fuck. He got how did he get me?
I was behind the fucking pole
Yeah, okay, let's let's go get some blessings, bro
Cuz I just brute force bosses, I'm gonna fight him one more time just because
Just because his second phase as he goes like all fucking
Looking quite grabbable and executable
Oh gasp. Yeah, he dodges to you. It's hard to dodge that. He dodges to you. He
He whatchamacallits to you
Bye, no
You can't get me you can't get me on the gingerbread man. You can't get me on the gingerbread man
Nope, he's right behind me, isn't he?
No, what the fuck is happening?
It's actually easier to dodge them when you get up real close just like Godwin, I mean Godfrey
Godric fuck there's so many fucking
What do you do stop using that fuck ass fucking spell, bro? Oh
My god, no West is
Oh
Yeah, I see to be a higher level I
Just need to be a higher level dodging. I honestly I didn't even notice he was at half half health yet
The Connie joke Cain Connie what the fuck am I saying?
All right, all right my eyes twitching
No, I am guy. I know when to say I'm beat I
Know when I'm not I am not strong enough nor skilled enough. I could brute force him
But I don't think that's fun to watch in my opinion. So I am going to I'm not skilled enough
I'm not skilled enough
I'm too and oh for bosses. I'll be real with you. Let's go find another place to go to
Tactical retreat. Oh, we can't get that. Oh, that's where I was all the way under there interesting
Where the fuck can I go this place is so fucking huge for no reason. Oh, how do I get to this map?
How do I get to that map
Skadoosh
Two lakes on your right. Oh
This map that one. Oh fuck. What the hell? How big is this place? I
Thought it was Lily. Oh my god. I'm gonna krill this one
It's limb grave size is this it wasn't that a joke that it's limb grave size
When math said for a morphe ruin go north there is a cave that leads West shirt. Okay
Where's Fort Morph I
Don't have that unlocked yet
Guys where's Fort Morph
Who the fuck is Dane, I don't know who Dane is
Oh
The twin moon lady this I
Mean what the fuck am I doing this that's castle ensus
What are you talking about I met him kung-fu who are you talking about?
You know what I yeah
Oh
Dry leave when did I talk to this dude? I
Don't recall I
Don't recall. I'm just gonna teleport there for a point of reference just cuz I don't know where it is. Oh
That guy oh all right, so we're here
Oh, what I thought I went over that
North e okay, okay, so now where do I go from here?
This one has a cave this cave over here
Right here right here Queens
This is a cave yeah, oh my god, let's do it Queens. We're here. We're here. We're ready to mingle we're single like a
Pringle I'm gonna touch your dingles. We're gonna run up
Like Chris Kringle
steel
Down a way down their chimney and scream bingo
You know
Who the fuck is aggroing me so do it on the horse
I
Bars bars
Bars what is that for you why there's so many of you guys around
You're like the Knight
riders
Knight rider theme plays. No, you're like the the night the night the night. I
Can't fucking think um
Where am I going? I'm going towards something the wrong way
Hold on I kind of want to see what this is though wait
No, I've already been over there
Wait, have I
Did I run through there? I
Know I'm hanging in the wrong direction. She's headed in the wrong direction. Did I go through here?
What this church of the crusade
Oh
Toasty oh
Sick bro, let's go
MPC invasion time that's too bad because I'm leaving
So
Remember that invader the dancing lion is yes
Yeah, I don't know why they didn't spawn
He's just like fucker. I'm just I'm so intimidated by this bunny woman that I I just can't do it
Don't invasions kick you off your horse they do they do kick you off your horse
If you beat oh, well, I never I never killed him remember
That's why I never killed that dude. I just ignored him. I
Never killed him. I really just I just I finished dancing lion. I just I never went back and killed him or anything
That's funny
Relatable oh my god, so relatable
I'm up too high aren't I am I gonna have to jump off this fucking cliff
I'm gonna jump off this fucking cliff
And death oh
My god, that's so fucking stupid brother
No perfect
We love a sick America
We love a sick America for those reasons where you can just jump and die in a steak America
And then you like that's what I would do them and there's a boss in
Learnea I just jumped off the cliff and landed either steak and I was like fuck
Oh, wait, no, there are no steaks in America of America in Learnea. You know what I mean? What the fuck are you?
Hello
Where did where did my runes go?
Queen that's fine. I don't really need them
What are these wormy motherfuckers? Why are some of them red and some of them just chilling?
So you're fine you're having a good time you're just being a hairy worm as hairy worms do
This is what guys guys with foreskin stick look like no kidding
I'm kidding. What it's spitting out come
Oh, I didn't even do anything to you bro. Why does that hurt me?
Why is it selling at the beginning of the use song
He wears his heart safety pin to his backpack his backpack is all that he knows
Isn't it doesn't doesn't the fucking violin sound like that
Shout down by strangers who plays this game cripple the heart and devour the soul
All alone he turns to stone while holding his breath
Hail from afar, I need that. No, I don't I can't fucking see past these for a few years
Can you give me a second? Does that go the wrong way?
Say I refied of what's inside too. Oh, you guys are kind of too powerful for no reason to save his life
He crawls like a worm from a bird
All alone
Can I fucking jump?
Girls that go where am I I can't see
Can I thank you
How the hell did I get over here what oh, I'm just on the other side what
That's correct
All right. Oh, how did that bird we get aggroed when I'm actually pretty far away from it. Oh
I kind of want to just look
Bullets it. Oh my god. What the fuck is that?
Grab your backpack. Let's go jump in vamanos
You can't leave no way. Hey, what the fuck are you guys doing over here? You guarding something?
Whatever it is. I want it. Hey, I'm an aggro all of you. Just guys are standing awkwardly
You know, you got nothing. It's fine. So many burbs
The thing I have a horse
Gravebird ankle it's ooh, I'm gonna be fashionable
Oh
Instead of normal birds they're great birds. Hi, don't mind me
Just checking on you. Just making sure you guys are good. You guys are hanging out
I just want I just want to be a part of it, you know
What do you have to know I keep thinking this is a person it's a fucking grave ah
Barb
More burbs a lot of burbs. I'll take you
Smithing stone
Well
Jumping up and down up and down
Oh, I thought that was a cliff and
raw
Raw raw roughs, but dear lover. Oh, it's a it's a it's a
It's a it's a ram
Love our oh of the rushing Queen we
I see that
The world map nearly three D so we've loops and twists and elevation
No, I don't think that I prefer like an actual and it's more true to the world, you know, they don't think you know
You know
Fuck
And
I'm the map how the hell did I get over here?
I'm assuming I can get over there and oh, yeah, baby, let's go
Yeah
At least the mind they just do it
They should just don't talk top of graphical more top of cap top of graph a little more top of graphical map
Sorry, I had a seizure. Oh
I missed you so much
Ha ha motherfucker, what the hell?
Serpentine serpentine serpentine serpentine serpentine serpentine serpentine you can't shoot serpentine
Hey
You missed
I'm pumping in his shot by a fucking arrow on the back serpentine
Wait, what are you doing? Are you a dude? Oh, you're a dude. Oh, you're dude that can hit me
Yeah
Please don't shoot me again, that's not very nice. I heard it. He missed I was a ring
La she blows
Yeah, raw ruins, how can that hit me? That's like pretty close damn
I feel like there should be a site of grace over here, don't you think?
I'm aggroed and I can't look at the map right now. Oh mushroom
I wish I would just try to double jump like I'm fucking torrent. Can I
My fucking huge armor, I can't do anything with it
I gotta break some rocks. I gotta do some shit
Yeah, yeah, where do I where the fucking rocks?
One it's stupid that this is a thing in the first place by the way, I think this is a stupid game mechanic
That is honestly pointless in my opinion
Like it's genuinely pointless
Like why do I need to go an extra mile of hitting a fucking rock?
What
Oh
It skips the rock part if I put the shackle that doesn't make any sense either that must have to be a game bug then
I don't see the
We I
Don't see the the like point
Where am I I'm still being aggroed who the fuck is aggroing me. I'm literally just flew away from you
I don't know where I'm going. I just wanted to go over here. Oh
I see I see so the blind man peeing in the wind. I'm still aggro
Can I please look at the map, okay, thank you. Thank you kindly. All right, that's a lot
Shit
Fuck
I don't even know where to go for that
There's a lot of things over here
This is a lot this is not limb grave size
This is like a little bit bigger than limb grave
Huh
All right, I'm gonna go back down if I can turn around properly
Where is it? Where's the hole?
We be funny if I died like I slightly just missed it
Easy there koofie
You can't reach the green area. Well, yeah, cuz you're in the bottom
That makes sense. I'm trying to think of what I can do over here. Maybe like go over to this place perhaps
Hey guys, what's going on tuppletown ruins? Oh?
Yeah, real nice. Oh
Is there like a tibia mariner around here like
What's what's going on? What's the deal with this place a roue?
Why don't I feel like I've been here already because it looks like another spot in the map. That's why
Come on torrent, I believe in you
Well, yeah, torrent. Are you fucking serious? You can't jump that I'm gonna cry
Torrent please I just I can't believe you right now torrent
Thank you. Oh my god. I
Was gonna say oh my god, please
Wow, that was worth it. That was so worth it. Um, I'm on top of this now
I'm being aggroed. Oh, hi. I was wondering who was that? Who goes that?
All right, it's really nothing of interest that I can see
Looking for a chest. Let me take this mushroom while I'm at it. Oh
The ghost of these ow. I
Was admiring your pot. I was about to make commentary upon your pot
Then you gotta throw your pot at me
Let's get a let's get a lay of the land
Hmm
Not a lot of land going on I'll tell you that much
Not a lot of land
It's from some shrubs in the walls I see I see
Shrubs in the walls shrubs in the walls. I'm in your walls shrubs in the walls. I
Honestly just want scout of three fragments. Excuse me
What the fuck is a spirit grave stone? I know it's probably part of those graves, but I'm like we're
Torrent I wish you could jump higher. I wish there was a torrent jump boost
That would be oh
Go away, I don't want your southern. How do I get in there? I'm trying to figure it out. I
Don't see a door
No fly goes near your skin
I'm not feeling this area. This area isn't speaking to me. I just passed it now
This dog is still fucking following me
I passed it
Door door door by some shrubs in the wall door
Door I'm being rock thrown at me in a pot Jesus fuck door door
Have to hug on this thing or have to hug the wall over there
You mean hug the wall over here
In the castle hug the fortress wall all right Queen I'll do as you ask
All right door
door
Don't door door door door door
Door what the fuck is this?
Hello, oh
Sorry, I didn't mean to break that
Was my fault. It was already like that when I got in here. Okay. Oh
Can you can you take your dogs away like I'm just dropping off your mail you don't have to stick your dogs on me
What is that?
Why is there a fucking tumbleweed here? Oh?
Goodbye
Can I
It's my son my right. Oh, I didn't mean to do that. Okay
Oh
Excuse me, I'm so sorry. I didn't mean to bother your dog
My dog kept going at me. So I just had to get it, you know
Poverty don't damage why is there a giant carpet on the you know, that's just that's a tripping hazard
They should really get rid of that and that's all I'm gonna say
That's quite the tripping hazard ma'am. I'm not done killing you yet ma'am
Excuse me, sorry, I killed your dog. You guys have a lot of dogs. They're just not nice
You should really put them down. I think they have rabies
Hey, I see you have a pot. Do you mind if I inspect it? Oh
Thanks
Damn, I just used my dick to break those. Do you see that damn I got I got a powerful pp
Bro, what is the point of this place? I see that right there. Like how do I get over there? I?
Hate this I hate this. This is like the most pointless area of the map so far
I'm just gonna
Oh
That's piss myself
I'm kidding. No, I didn't excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me. Excuse me
Excuse me platforming with torrent. Let's do it torrent
Don't let me down baby girl
Torrent I
Said don't let me down, baby girl
Torrent why are you like this?
Torrent you got it. I know you can do better. Torrent. Why am I the same size as you?
Like for a horse, you're kind of small. I
Just noticed that now, but if I do a little like a little quick like oh
There we go
Let me find if I got off the horse and I just fucking fell. Oh
Nice, okay, that was worth it. That was worth it. I will admit I don't
Hi, are you gonna attack me? No, you might you know you're minding your own business. I'm gonna let you mind your own business. Oh
What that
He's my pet yak yakity yak don't talk back yakity yak
Hey, I'm just gonna take that. Oh, it's arrows. I don't think he needed those anyways. Hello
Hello
Look at that fucking strut brother damn damn
Damn oh fucking bumped me
Oh, I can't I can't I can't I can't I
Does it say America? Yeah
My hands are sweating
Sweat baby sweat baby
It's like this take this job can you do the dynastop the only shit-cutting about so put your hands
Down my pants and I'll bet you feel nuts. Excuse me
Yes, I'm Siskelia some ember and you're getting two thumbs up
You've had a lot of two hand touch you want to rough your out of bounds and once you smothered once you cover like my
awful househouse friends
Cooker than coming quicker than FedEx. You need an effect. I don't I don't early. This is like daily saving time. Do it now
You and me baby ain't nothing but tarnished. So let's do it like they do on the
I can't think of any one thing that rhymes with tarnished
You and me baby ain't nothing but tarnished so let's do it like they do on the discovery channel
Getting tarnished now
Oh my god, he's fucking running I missed. Oh, but he missed. Oh
Oh, oh queen. No, do not step on me father. Can I?
Oh
Hold on. Let me just
Can we go back over here, please and then I'll fight you cuz like oh damn. Oh
My god, what the hell?
Ah, oh
I'm trying to get to the chest, but he's aggroing me so hard
I'll have to bring him like he walks go fat. He's he walks so fast
He walks really fast
So it's hard to just get to the chest and leave
Bro thinks he's the Dark Souls 3 tutorial boss honestly. Yeah, um, yeah, he's up there. I
Wish I could climb up there
Where am I?
Fuck
Love that kind you clean up with a mop and bucket like the last kind of combs of Egypt only God knows where they stuff
They're hieroglyphics only Pacific. I want to be down in your South Seas Bay got the notion of the motion your ocean means small craft advisory
I like to cap size in your thighs be five
Something something be five you suck my battleship. Please turn me on a mr. Coffee with that automatic drip
Oh
She'll call me yours. I'm calling you mine till time. You love me. Just like I'll then we'll do it doggy
So so we can both watch X files do it now
And you and me baby
I don't know why I know that's one tire song don't ask me why
Just just just don't ask
All right, maybe if I where am I going? Oh
Oh
Maybe I can beat him to fall off living in the sunlight laughing in the moonlight having a wonderful time
Hey cutie
You can do it put your back and sue it on I can do it put you on to it
You can do it put your back and sue it I can do it put your into it put your back into it put you into it
Come on Queen
Fuck me brother
You get all the way over here, I want you all the way over here
All right
Can't come over here this fast
Two-handed sword. Did I really need that?
Maybe. Where is he? Did he forget about me? Is there anything down here?
All right, this is pointless. Let's go! Well, it wasn't pointless. Um, is that a side of grace over there?
Killer?
Yippee!
I'm just trying, from that side. If only you two-handed sword, shut up, and shut up.
I didn't mean to say no.
Yeah, baby. Yeah.
Look at that. I am pure sex. I am oozing.
Demur. Just kidding. That's not how that word is. Um, okay, so we did that
sort of, not really. We could go up here.
No, it would literally just reach around, and that would be at a dead end. There's probably a cave over here.
It seems like there's some sort of...
Whatever the hell this is, I'm...
I'm...
All right.
Aw.
I say, how do I get to the green place? Oh, I probably have to clear...
I probably have to clear this castle, which looks quite legit.
This looks nice and small. Looks like there might be little flowers in there. Oh wait, I think that's the...
Where you fight the scorpion lady. No, I don't want to do that yet.
We could possibly...
What a pretty map. Look at the tree just dripping.
No, she's elsewhere. Scorpion lady's green. Oh, then what's... Oh, I thought this was like the...
The thing. Uh, I might just go over there then. Just a little bit more sporing. Let's do it.
Ooh. Okay, my name is running down the hallway. You will hear them momentarily.
I don't know how to get down there. Get down where? Oh, fuck, you're right. I have to get down.
Bro, this DLC is the most annoying to navigate.
Oh my fucking god.
Oh my god. Please. Why does this tree look like it's going to smack me and call me something inappropriate?
Hey again. What's up? Can I just hang out with you? Sick.
Did you just have like two... Looks like you have air pods in, but it's just... Why do you look like that?
I like... It's so funny because like you'd first look at them, you're just like, oh...
Why are you guys here? Wait, will it aggro him? Will they aggro him? I want to see if they'll aggro him.
Save me. Why are you still on my ass? Hit him, not me.
That's what happens. Ah!
He got them earbuds in, literally. I like how I sit at the side of grace and I fucking am hurt.
Save her, AirPodman.
He has them... He's the type of guy to wear...
Am I kintite?
Fuck is happening. I can't move my camera to look at him.
Alright. Oh, I'm locked on, that's why.
He's the kind of guy that wears the air pods but like buys the thing to make them wired.
Like how you can, like so you don't lose them from your phone, like that's what he does.
Like he gets a little, like he buys a little thing and he wraps it around his neck.
And he hangs himself, sorry.
Let me stand up here. Never mind.
You know, you should really stop doing pot, bro. That's like not good for you.
Not at all. There's a dog. Your dog is here. I have to kill you in front of your dog and I have to kill your dog.
Look at all this pile of weed and pot they had. Oh my god, terrible.
Horrible human beings.
Let me go sit down again.
God, it is really hard to like run around because like it's hard to explore because everything's a fucking cliff.
Let's go down here.
My neck hurts.
It cracked my neck but it didn't work out for me.
Did I just break my armrest?
I almost snapped my neck there.
Oh, that was awkward.
So I have to go through the big area.
Oh, fine.
Did I miss any scot-o-tree fragments?
Are there any scot-o-tree fragments that I'm missing and this and where I've been so far?
I'm just gonna look myself. I don't need you guys, you guys, you guys get overwhelmed when I ask you for help.
No, I want the actual fucking map.
Thank you.
Can I have the map, please? I just want the map. I just want the map. I just, I would like the map.
Give me, no, I don't care about Best Buy ads.
Oh my god, I'm going to fucking kill.
Okay, there's a lot that I missed. Holy hell.
Where am I?
Hold on, I can't see you guys. I can't see your little, your little quips.
There is 50 to get to level 20 because then you just buy three.
Okay, so where am I now?
Let me look at Scythe of Grace. Jesus fuck, no, that didn't help at all. Actually, no, it might.
Okay, I am at, nope, that's, I'm using my controller to try to control stuff. What the fuck am I doing? Stop.
Oh my god, that's because I'm using my mouse.
Okay, so I am at the three, no, am I?
Am I?
I am behind the Fort of Reprimand.
So, yeah, I think I got that. Did I get the Morph Ruins encampment? I think I did.
I still haven't gone to Bonnie Village. Where is Bonnie Village? No, that's down there. That's Bonnie Village is down here.
I thought it was on the same level. Okay, there's one in the center that I got. There's one over here. I don't know if I got it.
There's one over here. I just got that.
I don't know if I got all of them over here. I think I did. There's one over here. I'm pretty sure I got that.
I don't know. I probably didn't. There's some around here.
Cliff Road Terminus. I don't even have the grace over there. So I could go over there.
I haven't cleared this out yet. Fuck it. Let's fall. How do I get over there anyways? I don't even think I can. I don't even think I can get over there. Fuck.
What the sh-
Should I just go to the Shadowkeep? I feel like I can get over there.
I don't know.
Should I just go to the Shadowkeep? I feel like I should just go to the Shadowkeep. I think I'm just going to go to the Shadowkeep.
Can I combine my tabs, please?
What are you guys saying? Is that where I'm back with more of? Shall we do the five?
Okay. Let's try it. Let's try it. Let's try it.
You should make buffalo wings. Oh, so I'm freaking bomb.
I'm not ignoring you. I wasn't looking. The chat was closed.
Did I go in there?
I did. I don't know what the heck I'm talking about.
What's his name?
What?
Oh.
Okay.
So I go along here?
Is that what you're saying?
He's chill?
Okay.
Oh, do I get down there?
These deer are tweaking out.
Guys, are you sure?
Are you sure about that?
I don't know why. I generally shouldn't doubt you guys have actually played the game, whereas I have not.
All right, let's keep swimming. What the hell?
Ow, I started crying and I was going, what the fuck?
Oh my God.
Why are the NPCs so violent?
Oh my God, you're actually going to kill me.
Jesus Christ.
Frozen maggot. I feel like I should start calling you guys.
Interesting graves.
Acquire materials.
Where am I? What is that? I kind of want to see what that is.
Oh, it's this.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Oh, that was pointless. Never mind.
Okay, throwing it. You just throw hands? Unprovoked? I just walked up to them and stood there and they're like, you know what?
After your life, Bing Bong, who's a ghost puppy? Who's a ghost puppy chewing on a ghost person?
I'm dead. I'm not dead.
I just can't fucking platform them.
Okay, maybe I'll be able to grab this now that they're down there.
Please? Oh my God, torrent.
Oh, Jesus Christ. It's a fucking smithing stone. Wow.
He did that really badly.
Oh my God, that bat scared me.
I don't know, just like jumped out of nowhere.
I'd be going up to the bat to where am I?
Fabuloso. Let's take a seat.
Can you chill out for a second?
Matt, no, I'm not doing an arcane build. I'm doing a...
Intelligence, dexterity, strength build.
Because I just have a moon veil and I want moon veil part two.
Is this where I was before? Are you fucking serious? This looks like the same fucking castle I was at.
What?
What is that guy? Hello?
Jars?
What the hell?
Sorry, ew, you are ugly. Oh my God.
Do you drop anything interesting?
Let's see, how much damage? Oh.
Alright.
Huh.
The Yoda sword?
Is that the way they call it?
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Prospect Sound.
This doesn't really look like much of a town to me, to be honest with you.
It looks kind of dead. What do I have all the way over there?
Let's just yank that.
Go away. Thank you.
Alright.
Alright, let's bounce.
I thought that tree was a thing.
He's gonna walk.
Assuming that there'll be these guys. Let's see if I can aggro him.
Come out. Come on.
Come on.
I don't know if I fight the other one just for that yet.
Nice. Got me.
Got me.
What the fuck?
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh, interesting. You got blood?
That was a stupid thing. That's fine.
Sometimes I forget what I'm doing.
I keep forgetting to change my physics.
There's probably not a side of Grayson here.
Birds. Cool.
Cool.
Alright.
Got some pots.
It's alright.
We got some rabbit things.
Got something else. Let's make a noise.
Got some more birds.
We got some platforming.
You know, this is a nice...
I thought I was holding a giant fucking lollipop for a second.
Interesting so far.
Yeah, I'm scouting for frags.
Frag out!
I just throw a scat of tree fragment.
Oh my god. Sorry.
That was such a bad joke.
Oh my god.
Torrent, help.
Torrent, don't help that much though.
Wow, there's a lot of them.
There's, you know, hanging in.
Let's sneak around this way.
What are they chewing on?
She's just, like, watching?
Are they chewing on anything?
Are they just eating their own?
What the hell is happening here?
Is he sleeping and they're licking him?
What are they drinking?
I don't know.
I don't want to disturb them to be honest.
I don't want to disturb them.
I don't know.
I don't want to.
I don't want to disturb them to be honest.
They're doing their own thing.
I'll be over here.
He's just raising his staff.
He's monitoring the whole operation.
That was a chest.
Faboo.
Outer god heirloom?
Question mark?
I don't know what that means.
How did I get that?
I don't even remember picking that up.
Two-handed.
Wow!
Raises arcane.
That was worth it.
Okay, where's the scottachy fragment?
Where are you at, bitch?
Fuck, I can't jump over.
I don't know what that means.
How did I get that?
I don't even remember picking that up.
Two-handed.
I hear...
like, monster noises.
There must be one below.
A little flower.
Oh, thank you.
Sanguine amaryllis.
You picked it up at Castle A.
I thought there's one over here.
Am I stupid?
Yep.
Yes, there's one on the edge.
It's literally, it's...
literally...
right there.
Right there.
I can't see chat and I know you guys are going to be crying.
Oh the Talisman I got from Castling Hills, honestly, I can't jump down.
Let's see.
Do you have anything that I can?
What's that?
Wow, that was a hit.
Hey, I do you have anything?
I know you're just chewing on him and he's not like, why is there a Stake America here?
That doesn't make any sense.
Later nerds, later nerds, I hope you fall off the cliff and give me rooms.
What the heck?
Haha, bitches.
Whoa, whoa, what are you going to do about it then?
Oh, you're just going to stun them with your fonts and fonts with your fucking little thing.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
That's what I thought you little bitches.
Oh, I can't jump down there.
Yep.
All right, that's a very nice Stake.
That's a very admirable Stake.
Hi, got to go.
It was really nice seeing you though.
You're very, very sweet.
Okay, so there's a fragment around here somewhere.
What's that?
It's very, very strong.
Hmm.
This must be it right here.
No.
What the fuck?
What the hell?
What is shooting stuff?
A nice try, doggie.
Where is it?
What the fuck?
It's probably a guy.
Probably.
You're probably right.
Where are you, puppy?
Nope, that doesn't reach.
What are you doing?
Ow!
It's not nice.
Let me hit you.
It's Potman.
That's right.
Ever got it said that sometimes the dudes with the pots will have it.
Hey.
Hi.
Excuse me.
Where did Potbro go?
Potbro!
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Potman.
Whoa.
What?
What the fuck?
Where did this dude go?
Is he like a scarab?
Are you shitting me right now?
Oh my God.
That's stupid.
Like I'm standing here.
Like I just like post it up.
Like a real one.
Wait.
I'll like I'll euph post it up like a real one.
Hold on.
I'm gonna do this before I fucking forget.
So I have intelligence knots.
Clear.
And one of those two.
Wait.
What?
Why don't I have it?
to put faith. I meant to put this. Yippee! Let's get them, boys!
Da da da da da and subsidies Oh fairy kudos get the fuck over here motherfucker
Motherfucker, fuck that, fuck that, fuck that.
Pick it up, pick it up.
Okay, I did.
Hoot.
Okay.
Oh.
La la la la la la la la la la la la.
I was bouncing between songs.
Oh, barracuda.
Ta-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Yay.
Wow, she beat such a hag.
Hmm, a little thing though.
Na-na-da-na-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, did I not?
Frick!
Frick, I thought I had two.
Frick.
Frack.
throw okay did that that's fine whatever uh let's go to them all um i know there's so many
that i'm fucking missing but that's on me because i didn't i'll have to watch like a youtube
think i'm a barber on them um what else we got
what is that
all right this is close by then
so it is where
so
no i cannot get there yet
this is one over here in a cave
uh
i haven't been there though that's for sure
so i'm lucked by a boss there's a revered spirit ash nearby too bad i already disappeared
i already fucked off can i get there
what the
oh i'm looking at the wrong place what do i have
and pointed in this direction what the hell is this
what what is that
that oh it's the fingies it's the fingy place where you get fingied
i don't think so because it doesn't say that i unlocked it like it doesn't say that i um
usually it'll show like the the icon and bolded i don't think i did
but oh wait how the fuck do i get down there
yeah i have not been there yet um oh look a path down
that would have been a fun way down what did it
do
don't worry about it don't worry
don't worry about it i got it queen don't worry kings let it i know emmy says pookie a lot
don't worry pookie don't worry pookie there all right let's go
um no i have been here before did i grab the scatter tree fragments from here
i have been here
but it isn't showing that i like went inside
push mark
no i haven't been here what the fuck oh why is there so many of you
go away
a later nerd
don't let the fingy get close what do you mean what fingy there's no fingies around here
i don't see no fingies where am i do i want to go this way i'm kind of scared
i'm just scared oh it's over here stuff i can see you perhaps
you got anything good in here you go yeah i'm gonna break you finish it that was a dope
oh no i don't want to get ganked i don't want to get ganked
why can't i find like any weapons you know what um i don't quite know what's happening here
all right that was a little confusing to me
fire coil hmm but i've always wanted i like their outfits
it's a flask of america nearby don't they like just super your health i don't really care that
too much about that to be honest with you most of the remembrance uh most of them are tied to
okay that makes that makes sense a dog's gonna attack me in a second nope i didn't mean to
fuck i'm on fire i'm on fire no i didn't mean to fucking press that oh
fuck you dog now i have two things there oh my god please
oh
a wah oh can i go down here
oh fascinating quite fascinating i can make that i can make that not with this dog here
i'm kidding no i can't make that what is that
wooo
what is that then oh oh no oh
don't push me cuz i'm close to the
I just pushed myself to be honest. I don't really care about those runes. Let's get rid of these.
Okay, let's look. What else do I got around here?
I can't go to the hippo yet. The hippo guy. Mesbur's boyfriend.
I already got one of the three paths across. I already got one there.
Did I go to...?
I never went into this. Is this the arena that you fight him in?
Because there's scatotry fragments and there's two in here.
Explain. Is this the arena where you fight him? The dancing lion? I don't...
question. That's endgame stuff? Oh, that's the final area? That's where the gate is?
Okay, weird. Good to know.
No.
Lore reasons understood. All right, so we'll skip that for now because yeah, there's like three.
Wait, there's one in a secret room.
There's one in a secret room over here.
Is that also endgame? I'm assuming so. Unless there's like an area to get it over
if you go to the theater and there's one over here. Tell me, am I incorrect?
Could I get that to that?
No, yes. Waiting for you guys to type in for the latency to catch up.
It might be the one with the flights?
Okay. Oh, we'll save that then. So I did that, did that.
There's one near the pillar path cross. Nope, fuck.
Well, that's over here. It's literally right here. Wait, is it there? Question mark?
I can't tell if it's on the edge or if it's...
I can't tell if it's on the edge or if it's in this area.
Huh?
That's where sad... Who's sad poison boy? All right, let's go see sad poison boy.
Let's see how sad poison boy is doing.
Is that... Is that you guys? Is that... Are you guys sad poison boy? You love him?
Do you identify with him? Do you identify with this character? Is he you for real? For real?
You want to be sad? You love sad poison boy? Is he cute? Like,
can I use him as a physical representation of you guys in game and just like
make sweet sweet love to him or something? Is he cute? Maybe? All right, I'll see.
Is he like handsome and got it bopping? Like, is he... Oh, Swift Spear. Wow, I need that.
He wears a mask? Oh, you know, I'm into that. I'm into, you know, that's why you, you know,
harlots wear a mask. I like a little bit of mask play, you know, just like, you know,
scream guy. Oh, there's a side of grace over here.
Oh my god, is that him? Is that poison boy? Who won? Is that soldier boy?
Oh my god, if I can fucking get off the horse.
He only wants to sleep. What are these?
Empyrean blood? Hi! Hey, oh, you know, oh, you look like a femme boy to the extreme.
You know, I like myself a femme boy. I like all types of boys.
Oh, he sounds so cute. I am. Oh, I'm gonna peg the shit out of you.
Oh, yeah. Oh, Tiaulia. That's a gay ass name, but you know, you're kind of cute.
You're really pretty hair. Yeah, you just turn around.
Turn around. You don't have to be good at this. Just take your ass up in the air.
Oh, are you now? You know, I like that about you.
Can you poison these nuts in your face?
Ooh, toxic musling.
You know, I'll come back to you, cutie pie. Let's chat.
What can I help you with? Oh, let me take off that mask and see what that mouth do.
He's so you. He got, he really is. You get like, this is you guys right here. I'm just gonna,
I'm a fat bastard right now, but he's a fat ugly bastard right now. But you know, just
if I just take you, he has a quest line. Interesting.
Cool.
Sick. We're at seven.
If you travel further up the cliff following the, you'll hear the other members of chat. What do you
mean? I go up the cliff where people just chat to chat and shit. Are they, are they have the chat?
Rada. Rada, rada. Let's see. Where else do we go? What do you mean?
Him. Who's him?
Okay, and then the rest are kind of in places I can't get to. What the hell? Is there some in the
fucking ocean? What the hell? I'm assuming that's below. How do I look below?
Okay.
Two in the fucking ocean. I can't fucking accidentally put them to bed.
Okay, and the rest are kind of later in the map.
Is this one in the castle front?
Oh, is this where Mesmer is? Oh, no, not Mesmer.
Oh, Mesmer, daddy. Little abandoned boy with mommy issues, Mesmer. Okay, I think I can like it up to
underground. What the frick?
Okay, I go up the cliff. What do you mean? Which way? Which way up the cliff?
This cliff that I'm facing over here?
Okay.
West.
And head south? Okay.
Is this the rest of you guys? Are these you?
Moning masochistic men. What?
Am I going the right way?
Keep going. All right, if you insist. Oh, there's a side of grace over here.
Oh, hello.
Are you good?
Um.
Where are your legs?
Hey.
Oh.
Yeah.
There is life in me yet. Are you screaming about a dragon?
Yeah, when I'm taking a shit.
All right.
All right. That's great, bro. Um, can I kill you? No, I'm kidding. I won't kill.
Why don't you hear? I thought I heard boss music for a second.
She be after a milkshake. Oh my god. Fowl.
What's over here? I don't think I've been over here yet.
These birds? Are they statues? I can't fucking tell.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that. I feel like one of these things is not like the other.
One of them real. Oh, it's you. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Oh, you're funny. You're real funny.
Can I? Ow. Jesus fuck.
And the rest are pretty real. Yeah, you're real.
Like how they jump on the ground. How did something die?
It's over here. Is there one over here? Oh, they're just like hanging up.
That one has something. I don't know. It's like blowing and shit.
Oh my god. It's a bird. Bird bath over here. I can't get up.
I've fallen and I can't get up. I know. I don't need to use target lock. I already fucking know.
I won a voice act as an NPC in a soulsite game. That is my dream.
I just want to be like, oh, hi there.
I suppose you're wondering why I'm here. Well, I'm just a funny girl, you see, and...
I don't fucking know.
Oh, something in my eye. What the fuck just got in my eye? Playing with one hand.
Ah, bitch. My eyes are twitching and there's something in my eye.
What's in here then? What's in the tower then? I kind of want to go around the tower.
Suppressing pillar. Suppressing my emotions pillar.
Let's check it out. I always play with one hand, brother.
Theater. I would be, I can go so good for my voice acting. Don't even try me.
I can get really into it. You guys don't hear it on Patreon as much because it's paid. What the fuck?
It's Patreon. Is it going to teleport me somewhere? What's this?
Why is there an ancient dragon smithing stone just up here? Anyways, yippee.
I still have something in my eye. I'm telling you. I got it out. I'm telling you.
I like how they freeze. Like there's like red light fucking green light over here.
Yep, bitch.
Nice try. You almost got me there, Batman. Batman riddle me this.
For the view and some more, yeah. And this dude just screaming for no reason.
I'm just gonna do that real quick.
Because I can, I'll do with my whole, my whole soul. I'll be the best voice actor. Okay.
Oh, my shit's over there. I totally forgot. I don't really care that much about that. I suppose
let's go, what is this? I haven't been over there yet.
Let's go to the shadow of Keep of Mesmer. You think it'd be a more interesting name?
Like I thought I think it'd be more intense. Is there a way to get down there?
Because I would like to clear other things out. Like I'd like to get over here and here.
Can I jump down there? Ah, she'd be half like, oh, I should go far.
Follow the path towards the dragons.
Yeah, this way.
Let's do it. Nothing to it. They beheaded every dragon in these parts.
Let me kill this bird. Oh, my God, please.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Ancient dragon man. Why the fuck is he all the way over there? Take your time.
Take your time.
Oh, that's a fucking sick outfit you're wearing, though, dude. I really like it.
Don't you dare fucking heal. I'm gonna keep spamming you. I know and I should play a lot
smarter, to be honest with you. Oh, my God, you're gonna kill me. No, I don't want to, too.
No. No. Why am I feeling like I'm having this kind of a delay?
That was weird. Can you drop something interesting? No? Are you shitting me right now?
I was hoping to get your fucking bomb-ass fit, dude.
Anyways, am I gonna fight a dragon? Let me step on this little...
It's a broken room.
See, guys? I can fight. I'm good at what I do. Fuck this bird.
Is there anything over here? I don't feel like... Oh, my God, I'm lagging a little bit.
Oh, there's a cave in it. I'm assuming I'm gonna fight a magma man. I don't want to fight a magma
worm. You could become a dragon? What? A dragon's pit. That's what I call my armpit.
Is that a boss thing over there?
Good luck. Oh, great. Hold on. Let me go pee before I do this. Oh, my neck. You hear that?
Let me check on Fia as well.
I'm sorry. I'm taking so long.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
But we want some attention, so I'm giving you attention.
Wait for me.
You like, um, give me a hug, because I'll stand up on his hind legs and call on my shoulder if you want to hug.
You, you're so quick today.
You're so good. Might as well just help me with food.
Is that everything? Oh, I need a brush. Oh, my God.
Let me get rid of this. Let me go get some water.
Water, water, water.
I feel like I should eat something.
I have to eat some breakfast.
I have a bowl of cereal.
The milk may kill me, but we'll see.
I'll see if the milk kills me.
He's not a horse.
He's getting the figures a horse.
Hi.
I know.
Hi, Chad.
What are you doing?
Looks like you're trying to ask yourself a dessert.
Oh.
All right.
Okay.
I got cereal.
It's Cheerios.
I'm going to need to work on my fine motor skills.
Take a lactate.
You can't tell me what to do.
I have my hands up.
Ah, my headphones.
That was a pretty good joke.
Hello, sir.
Can I help you?
I'm being accosted by my cats.
Both Rena and Boomi are over here trying to get my cereal.
Oh, my God, Boomi, you're so much bigger than Rena now.
Oh, my God.
I never really looked at the size difference, but Jesus Christ.
Rena's really staring at my spoon.
Your dad voicing your model hit div TV on.
That's funny.
Stop hitting on my dad.
Everybody's gay for my dad.
You're here for me and me only.
Not my parents.
No.
It was fun spending time with them.
My dad just can't make any dad jokes.
So did my mom.
She was so funny.
I'm making fun of my laugh from the golfing club because I showed them the golfing club.
No, he did not get his 50 bucks.
Yes, my parents are married.
What's the outfit today?
A mummy outfit?
Oh, no, it's not.
I'm not wearing toilet paper.
I swear.
I am.
Rena, you can't have this.
It's like.
Oh, come on.
I have no legs.
I hold on.
I'll do some.
That's my surprise face.
I'm sweating.
Blushing and sweating.
No.
Rena, you can't have the milk.
It will literally puke.
You literally puked this morning because you tried to steal my milk.
Rumi, you either.
None of you can have it go away.
Oh, my God.
We're so big.
What else do I got?
What else?
And I'm like,
what were you doing, Harlett?
What were you up to?
Harlett?
Excuse me.
I can't believe you want to go out with my dad.
You don't want to stay with me.
Oh, my God.
We'll be drinking the milk.
What does this do?
Oh, what?
Huh?
What?
Oh, it's getting cut off.
I don't know about that.
Oh, this is the heart eyes that kept it white.
Yeah.
Bum Exam Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bum Bow Bow
Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee
Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow Mee Bow
Birmingham MGM
What?
You're stupid, you're double stupid, you're triple stupid, you wanna hug?
You wanna hug?
Do you wanna hug?
You wanna hug, don't you?
You want a hug from me, your madam?
Come here, let me give you a hug, and we'll give you a smooch, muah, muah, muah.
That just takes off that, this makes me flat-chested.
Flat, flat.
Ah, it's my head's too big.
My head is too big.
Let's do anything?
Nope.
Yeah, that's stupid, the fucking wedding which thing got claimed, because of the Halloween music.
I don't know why I'm using my ring of voice, hold on.
Sometimes she just slips out when I'm in cutesy mode.
It's just like demonetized, I don't really care.
I told the manager to appeal it and stuff.
No, that's not on YouTube, it's just people like false claiming and stuff.
I'm trying to copyright stuff that doesn't belong to them.
It's almost time, oh frick, I gotta go.
I almost forgot about the members.
I didn't realize what time it was, I thought it was like four, holy crap.
Aw.
Thank you for reminding me.
Alright, yeah we're still doing it, you kidding me, why would I just cancel that?
Just to point the freaking out of the drink.
No.
Alright, bye.
I'll see the members in a second.
Can I raid myself?
Will that work?
Can I raid into my own stream?
Is that a possibility?
Can I raid into a member stream?
Oh it says from other channels, no you can't raid into yourself.
Why did Stronny say I could raid into myself?
That's not a thing.
Alright, well.
What's happening?
I'm leaving.
No, even my own streams I can't do.
They don't show up.
Hi Mari, bye Mari.
Whoops, I'm late.
Just like my, oh my fuck it.
Okay, I'm gonna go do a member stream.
Bye.
Bye Stinkies, bye.
After the member stream, you might do a little bit more, Elden Ring.
Bye.
No, they can't, I'm so sorry Mari.
You have to be a member tier, not emo tier.
Bye.
Go to, if you remember, go to my stream.